alexis bonjour très heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors emmanuel macron on le disait est
aujourd'hui à stains pour promouvoir la
plateforme un jeune une solution les
jeunes sont-ils les grands oubliés de la
gestion de la crise du coronavirus par
l'exécutif
oui clairement ça fait longtemps
d'ailleurs que la larme a été lancé un
par les associations les syndicats et
les jeux de même à isolée incapable
d'avoir des cours à l'université avec
ses pensées suicidaires certains qui
sont passés à l'action la précarité
aussi cetc queue devant les banques
alimentaires qui ne font que s'allonger
avec les plus jeunes obligés d'avoir
recours à ces banque alimentaire pour se
nourrir
donc oui les jeunes ont été largement
les oubliés de cette crise alors on voit
bien emmanuel macron essaye de leur
parler via les influenceurs il a fait
appel à maclas et carlito pour faire une
vidéo pour rappeler les gestes barrière
gabriela talent qui invite aussi des
influenceurs à l'elysée mais là encore
l'elysée s'est pris les pieds dans le
tapis de sa propagande avec les
étudiants qui ont dit on est étudiant
pas influenceurs c'est un peu mal placé
d'inviter des jeunes qui sont
extrêmement bien payé pour faire ce
métier d'influenceurs qui ne sont pas
étudiants qui ne connaissent pas la
réalité
alors pourquoi faire ça si ce n'est
encore davantage de mépris et davantage
de violence vis-à-vis de ses plus jeunes
alors emmanuel macron passe à l'action
exit les influenceurs enfin ce plan là
va rester mais là il est dans le concret
il est à stains aujourd'hui
effectivement pour promouvoir cette
plateforme du gouvernement un jeune une
solution et surtout inauguré un nouveau
campus de 11000 mètres carrés financé
par la fondation total qui s'appelle
l'industrie tu là il est question de
former les jeunes aux métiers
industriels sans qualification les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans il est encore quoi
qu'il en coûte le président de la start
up nation puisque plutôt que mettre en
place un grand plan d'état ils le
demandent l'aumône aux grandes
corporations
là il s'agit de la fondation
total qui ouvre un campus plutôt que de
donner des moyens à l'éducation
nationale à la recherche à l'université
cdu emmanuel macron pur jus
et puis ce plan un jeune une solution a
été lancé en juillet l'idée c'est de
proposer des emplois et des stages il a
été dit qu'il y aurait environ cent
mille offres d'emploi et de stage mise
en ligne
mais il se pourrait vite que ce plan un
jeune une solution soit vite un plan un
jeune un stage ou un jeune un métier
précaire malheureusement il avait devant
la la ministre du travail sera aux côtés
d'emmanuel macro à stains la ministre du
travail qui a assuré que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage se poursuivait
est-ce que c'est toujours cette
politique lui en même temps alexis bah
oui c'est même au delà du même temps
c'est un cynisme assez rare est un peu
la marque de fabrique un des malades
macro et de son gouvernement d'un côté
dire quelque chose de l'autre en faire
une autre lutte et prétendent lutter
contre la précarité et remettre sur la
table cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage
c'est vraiment du cynisme elisabeth
bornes le ce bar pour que revienne cette
réforme promis par emmanuel macron
l'idée c'est assurer davantage d'équité
entre ceux qui avaient des hauts revenus
et qui avait davantage dead lorsqu'il
était au chômage
enfin on parle de 4500 euros bruts pour
avoir de moins d'allocations au bout de
neuf à sept mois
et puis l'autre c'est lutter contre les
contrats courts avec des points de bonus
malus aux entreprises seulement les
partenaires sociaux sont vent debout
contre cette réforme qu'ils tombent
extrêmement mal je pense qu'il faut la
mettre tout simplement à la poubelle
compte tenu de la crise sanitaire et de
la crise économique qui est devant nous
en disant qu'avec cette réforme est bien
ce serait environ plus de 40 % des
allocataires qui verraient leurs
allocations baissé de plus de 22% donc
très tendue lutter contre la précarité
en poussant à la précarité des gens qui
sont en recherche d'emploi sachant que
l'emploi va se faire rare et que les
plans sociaux vont se multiplier
on est vraiment dans du grand n'importe
quoi plutôt que durant en même temps et
alexis que penser de la gestion actuelle
un sens véritable horizon ou date de
retour à la normale alors là c'est une
gestion qui inquiète les marchés parce
qu'on navigue à vue en france et ça
commence à se voir
aucune date de retour à la normale entre
guillemets l'économie n'aime pas
l'incertitude les marchés non plus
et donc ça commence un peu à tanguer en
disant mais qu'est ce qui nous attend
finalement on ne lutte pas contre une
épidémie à coude amende de 135 euros de
couvre-feu à 18h et d'enfermement des
français de loin du littoral le week-end
donc ça fait extrêmement peur ça fait
aussi une question sur le quoi qu'il en
coûte combien va coûter ce plan est ce
que c'est possible de tenir encore
combien d'entreprises zombies qui
finalement soutenu par ses plans dès
devons mettre la clé sous la porte qu'on
photo d'un rebond attendu par bruno le
maire à tel point d'ailleurs que le fmi
s'en inquiète
il a fait des modélisations basé sur la
révolte républicaine de 1832 en france
en disant que les crises sanitaires
souvent débouche sur des crises sociales
et le parallèle se fait dans les dents
l'espère du fmi et de la recherche en
dix ans la en france on est en train de
jouer avec des allumettes
parce que même si le plan de relance
financés par l'union européenne et par
nos impôts surtout est censé remettre
l'économie à flot rien n'est moins sûr
et aujourd'hui c'est surtout ce manque
d'horizon ce manque de certitudes qui
fait que personne ne sait à quoi
s'attendre dans cette sortie de crise
merci beaucoup alexis on vous retrouve
évidemment pour l'édito politique comme
chaque lundi dans la matinale